horrific and tragic news coming out of
Laval as police have confirmed two
children were killed when a city bus
crashed into their daycare earlier this
morning we know police had received
9-1-1 calls at around 8 30 after
residents reported hearing a huge bang
when they arrived on scene they saw a
bus in this daycare that has the
capacity to welcome up to 80 children at
once neighbors came onto the scene
describing scenes of horror children
screaming they had tried to pull a
couple of kids out from under this bus
meanwhile this bus driver who is a 51
year old city bus driver for the Laval
bus service was described as hysterical
coming out of this bus screaming having
removed his clothes that two or three
men who lived nearby detained him had to
punch him and hold him down until police
could come and put the handcuffs on him
and arrest him we now know that that man
has been charged with dangerous driving
and and with homicide of course those
two children have passed away we know
that six others were seriously injured
but their lives are not in danger right
now
where the bus crashed into a daycare
obviously we're all hoping and praying
that the kids are all right that they
pull through and get well soon I can't
imagine what the families are going
the federal government can do will be
there but I know the First Responders
and everyone is very active on this
right now it's terrible what happened
this morning in Nevada so uh
and Christopher's Keith will go to Laval
and all my thoughts are with the
children with the parents and with the
employees there is a school behind me
that police are using as a sort of
operation Center they have been meeting
parents there many parents have been
reunited with their children we've seen
parents leaving here who have just been
clutching their children very tightly
some people just in tears but of course
for some parents the news is just an
absolute nightmare as we now know that
two have passed away Dan Spector Global
News label